here we go rob zombie ladies and
gentlemen how are you sir good good
thanks for being here man push it yeah
that's awesome three from hell comes out
tonight yes finally it's such a crazy
leap that you've made I mean people know
you as much now for your films as they
do for your music yeah pretty much
especially well I've really noticed that
would not be like in an elevator like
the music fans I can pretty much spot
them you know but like when some guy
comes up to me an elevator it looks like
he's a lawyer or something which I I
have to get to grips with out cuz I'm
not you know I'm old every time a cop
comes up in like what is this guy one
like like a fan because these thirty
years younger than me well I get with
normal people I go man I'm so into this
or that because you know I figured like
you know
heavy metal music is very specific but
everybody likes movies right yeah yeah
I can pretty much spot them what do you
look for metal feel like what what do
you see it like what's coming your way
well it's change but now it's always a
guy with a shaved head and a long goatee
that's very nobody has a yeah nobody has
hair anymore it's like I swear sometimes
about stage the physics that's funny
yeah right that was rock and roll
synonymous yeah it's like not not
anymore what made you make that leap in
horror films well I always wanted to
make movies that was always my main goal
in life
really before music well it was well let
me back it up I loved everything equally
but as a kid it all seemed unattainable
so it was all of a fantasy like oh yeah
I'm gonna go to Hollywood make movies oh
yeah I'm gonna have a band like no
you're not you're just living in some
crap town you're gonna do nothing is
what it felt like her up in Haverhill
yeah yeah you're on the Newton oh yes so
fine I think when I was a kid and played
ice hockey we would play against you I'm
sure like 30 seconds like those are
worse 30 seconds of my life
then oh yeah growing up I mean it's like
you can have a crappy band in the garage
with your friends but it's not gonna do
thing and then we had a super 8 camera
so we'd make
happy super 8 movies but not enough it
seemed realistic I thought my life was
gonna be you know world's worst bike
messenger New York City that's seem to
be what I was destined for but then as
the band started taking off and which
seemed odd in its own and there was a
chance to make music videos like [ __ ] it
I'm directing these music videos this
will be film school for me and that's
what it's what it became did you have
this thing that a lot of people have
when things start going well for them
you have sort of like imposter syndrome
like you kind of you you like is this
what the [ __ ] are they gonna find out oh
yeah my whole life is like yeah fooled
them again I think everybody feels like
that I think so too I mean I cuz I was
always so I was so shy and if I was so
shy I wouldn't even like want to talk to
people on the phone when I was a kid
because I was too much yeah that one day
I realized I just this is how I realized
it one day like in in high school I
didn't associate with anyone like no one
remembers me because I was just
invisible but me and my friends were
sort of like into punk rock like in a
place where like no one knew what that
was though and then the day we graduated
we were at like hanging out around
McDonald's and the main [ __ ] jock kid
came up who would be the worst your
worst enemy who started like hey man I'm
going to college what do you guys get
like your cool clothes and stuff it was
four years of torture from you your
douchebag friends and now the day we
graduate like hey you guys so that's
what I knew everyone's so [ __ ]
insecure it doesn't matter and then the
next day I was like I don't care anymore
oh that's a different person
yeah it's forgive those people you know
the people that [ __ ] with you in high
school
it's hard to let that go and realize
though they just were probably tortured
at home well you can't let it go because
that's your motivation
I'm always motivated by probably by
anger and revenge and things of that
nature that's why when people want
anti-bullying I go might be anti success
later on a life because you know people
to get [ __ ] with tend to make it yeah
Chris Rock has a bit about that yeah
it's true I mean certainly true for
fighters almost all the best fighters in
the UFC have some story where someone
was [ __ ] with them and they're young
I mean how to figure out how to fight
yep
what's the first thing we all do take
karate
yeah believe it Chris Rock's bit
involves Steve Jobs and a lot of other
people like do not want Microsoft like
yeah no it's super true it is super true
and it's also soup it's interesting that
you said that you were you had social
anxiety so many people that become
entertainers also had some form of
social anxiety when they're young yeah I
had to do this thing last no the night
before last I was presenting this award
to somebody at this event and you know
I'm picturing how the stage will be
really big and high you know I can get
up there it's super impersonal doesn't
matter and I get there the stage is like
lower than this desk and it's like all
the tables with people eating dinner
right they're like oh man's nightmare I
can't do this yeah you know cuz you have
to sort of be normal I used to freak out
when I had to talk to bank tellers I
used to like you know you're in the line
doesn't make no sense right but the line
of like I'd have to deposit my check and
I'd be in the line I'm like four more
people and I got to talk
morley know that feeling I was like that
about every I like that was my own not
my family that lived in the house but
like an uncle came over I can't do a
deal and Target Uncle Bill upstairs call
me when he leaves yeah and then it's
crazy that a guy like you winds up
singing in front of [ __ ] thousands of
people playing guitar in front of
thousands of people I wish I could play
guitar but I will sing in front of
people um it doesn't bother me
it does matter like oh it's a festival
it's a hundred thousand people I'm like
who gives a crap it's crazy so it's two
people out they don't want to say hi oh
my god that's weird
yeah especially if they're right in
front of you like the one of the
weirdest shows that any comic ever has
to do is shows where there's a really
tiny audience like the Comedy Store at
one o'clock in the morning and there's
like five people that's brutal it's just
so weird it's like 500 people no problem
yeah five people ah that's why starting
like when which people like ha do you
ever go back and play clubs and more
intimate saying like no no I want the
shows to be bigger as in it's impersonal
as humanly possible because I hated
playing clubs and the people like right
in front of you like you know yeah
I feel like I know we do kind of suck
bikini just go with it getting a break
man you know let us get our feet I don't
know what kind of music did you guys
play in the very beginning well when I
started I was living in New York City
and when my first band White Zombie
started I was working at pee-wee's
Playhouse actually as a production
assistant for Pino yeah first season did
you know Phil Hartman I know I was a
production assistant
I thought people aren't cuz it's Phil
Hartman and it was Paul Reubens
obviously it was William Marshall who
played Blacula he was the cartoon King
at that point there's all these great
people Larry Fishburne was cowboy Curtis
that's trying to think who else is here
wow I forgot he was on it the only
interaction I ever had with anybody was
Paul Reubens and I was staying in there
and he walked by he goes where's the
bathroom it's right there that's it yes
that was it so I figured oh but it's
crazy that white zombie was your first
band - yeah and one of the odds it was
weird because we didn't play any covers
and we sort of nobody really knew how to
play when we started we sort of invented
sound based upon completely not knowing
what you're doing really yeah because
yeah that's like any band like The
Ramones it's like well we know these
three chords but we understand they
instinctively understand catchy pop
songs even though it doesn't make sense
because when you try to learn a Ramones
song it doesn't make sense even though
it seems like all these really simple
songs because I've played them before
because I've done this Ramones tribute
thing like oh verse chorus
wait verse again two courses that are
not like they're so catchy but the
structure is so odd because you could
tell they were just sort of inventing
this thing they're doing and that's how
I felt with us because I had this weird
idea like let's never play conventional
drum beats which is like saying let's
never make the song fun for anyone to
listen to I got over that but but it's
just yeah you just I don't know talking
about did you take any classes in the
early days or did you just
well I went to New York originally go to
Parsons School of Design for Fine Arts
but I got kicked out cuz my grades
dropped to low because I went from
Haverhill to New York so I was like I'm
just hanging out dance at Arial all
night I'm not going to school because
Dan cetera was amazing cuz one night it
would be you know
brendi MC like before anyone knew who
they were and then it would be like Nick
Cave then it'd be this was like I was i
stayed that every night till 4:00 a.m.
and then would go to school and just you
know fall asleep or fall asleep on the
train ride home in new jersey then try
to get back so you never went to school
like like for classical musical
instruments or anything no and everyone
i i can't learn anything I'm think I'm
incapable I just have to do it and
figure it out and do it wrong a thousand
times I can't I just didn't Capitol even
was a little kid if we got a game I was
incapable of reading the directions we
would just let's just make up our own
rules
we got a spinner and these little guys
let's just know it was like three lines
of directions to learn how to play the
Happy Days game we wouldn't bother
you're giving so many kids out there
hope right now listening to this they're
like that's me yeah I mean if you can
make it you can be you could be Rob
Zombie can be an idiot and make it I
mean I remember when I got kicked out of
school I was sitting in New Jersey I was
probably 19 maybe 20 and I was just
sitting there thinking well I did it I'm
a [ __ ] loser because I had you know I
was making like 100 bucks a week I got
kicked out of school I was sitting there
in this crappy ghetto neighborhood in
Jersey City here's two of my life it
worked out yeah it worked out somehow
isn't that crazy
just things just eventually get better
yeah yeah oh and you I don't know how I
guess I don't know how because it never
they would never seemed like it was
going to like white zombie was a band it
seemed like everyone hated and no matter
what we had to be literally the last
band in New York City to get a record
deal maybe that's why we got it like
literally out of bands we have to sign
them but even when that happened there's
always this weird thing and maybe you
could really we got it offered a record
deal with RCA Records now we're a band
that hasn't got anything and I was like
nah doesn't seem right
it down and then we got MCA and I turned
it down as like I think we should wait
hold out for Geffen Records now that we
have nothing
this is people holding out for Geffen
Records because they were the biggest at
the time with no reason to be holding
out but we got to sign a Geffen
eventually did you have those kind of
balls because that seems like you well I
think it's balls mixed with stupidity at
the same time because I I know I could
be my own worst enemy because you want
to sign the Geffen you know I come up
with an album title they're like really
you're gonna call it less Exorcist Oh
devil music vol 1 is this just to
guarantee we don't get any good
placement on the album in stores I guess
and then like well we're gonna hire
let's hire so-and-so to direct the video
[ __ ] naming you know he just did that
naming some bait the Whitesnake video
like now I'm gonna do it but it all
worked it's crazy though that you passed
on to legitimate record companies I
wouldn't mean most kids when they're
starting out or so you know you're like
holy [ __ ] this is our chance I didn't
think they were good enough you know we
weren't good enough for anything either
I don't know what that thought was well
maybe you just I'm not a believer in
fate but it kind of seems to fall into
place for you it yeah I don't know it's
like I feel like my whole life is just
like I could have gotten hit by that car
I just didn't yeah cuz I just stopped
one second short from actually stepping
in front of a speeding car and made it
so you always wanted to make movies
though that was always some that was
always the thing I wanted to do for sure
but that seemed completely undoable
because it was just like Hollywood and
movies I mean it just it feels so far
far removed I mean living on the Lower
East Side playing CBGB's like and being
broke that seems doable like right you
know and that actually inspired me
there's I would see so many bands like
oh well they suck I mean we at least
better than they are
I guess the motivation I had but like
movies just seemed like no way that
works for comics too that's one of the
best thing Richard Jeni once said that
about open mic nights that really bad
comedians are great because they inspire
people to try it yeah yeah yeah I get I
because this is such a me I think I I
so many friends that are comics that
I've always become good friends with
over the years and I think it's so
similar
I can't imagine staying there trying to
tell jokes that people aren't laughing
but I also can't imagine staying there
playing songs that nobody wants to hear
and they're just looking at you like
yeah yeah kinda similar well the thing
is I think it's probably even harder
maybe with songs that nobody knows
because people will listen to jokes
because they make them laugh but songs
that that one knows in a band that no
one knows like man you got to figure out
a way to rope these people in yeah
that's why I always figured like I was
always visually oriented so I always
would made sure the band had a look a
certain way in act a certain way the way
I wanted them to be you know so I
thought at least there's that at least
you can go this is awful but look at
these maniacs wear it you know
everybody's hair is down here and
they're going crazy and no one else is
going crazy in the club but they are at
least it's you know an entertaining
trainwreck to watch at least you know
what kind of films did you like when
you're growing up I mean when I was a
kid I would literally just get the TV
Guide cuz we're talking like you know
the early 70s and I would circle
everything that I was gonna watch for
the week like I would plan it out it
wasn't random it was like okay one
o'clock white Heat's on I'm gonna watch
that beneath the Planet of the Apes
comes on at four we're gonna jump to
that then you know gonna take a break to
watch Gilligan's Island then want to
come back cuz good and bad news on
tonight cuz it's Clint Eastwood week and
I would just plan it out the whole week
and that's I would just watch everything
kids today will never understand TV
guides now never understand and then
ones that would come with the Sunday
paper you get the the guide with the
paper you figure out what's what's gonna
be on your greatest diver we would look
forward to what was going to be on TV
remember as a kid like you knew Planet
of the Apes was gonna be on like the
whole neighborhood was on fire cuz
Planet of the Apes was gonna be on
outside whatever it's on my phone right
now
it's always there yeah but I think
there's something I don't you think and
I don't know how this figures into
comedy but I'm sure it does there was
something about having to be exposed to
everything because there was nothing
else that I know as much about John
Wayne movies as I do
about horror movies right you didn't get
to choose where is now everything so
compartmentalized that people just like
you guess like if you hear a band go let
me guess what your favorite band is the
band you sound exactly like because you
have no other influences as opposed a
lot of metal bands I know that are huge
they go well my favorite band was
actually ZZ Top so we just decided to
play ZZ Top riffs really fast and that's
how we created this but everybody's just
so like I only like this yeah they get
in those those confirmation bubbles
where everybody else likes what you like
and yeah you just operate in the same
circles and yeah yeah you can get real
weird that way where it's weird like you
just it but if you're taking influences
for stealing things from everywhere you
know you can put them together in new
way but if you like I only like metal
yes you smell like metal that's the cool
thing about the radio right that I mean
I've been recently listening to Spotify
which I never listened before but listen
to streaming services I exposed to you
know there's like a channel like
there'll be a Rob Zombie channel and
there'll be a bunch of other [ __ ] on it
as well
like you know exact one channel here's
some weird music that you you didn't
expect from some bands you didn't even
know of and I've missed that from radio
yeah I mean I just want to because you
want you want that motorbike AHA whoa
what's this yeah yeah that's [ __ ]
cool I'm gonna listen to that I didn't
know what it was five minutes ago yeah
you know and now I'm because even as a
kid I mean I hate totally gonna spike
you know but it's like you know I just
FM Raiders like okay the Allman Brothers
then Diana Ross then kiss then ABBA I'll
just listen to all of it cuz it's on the
radio right right you know yeah I
remember growing up in Boston remember
WB CN oh yeah sure yeah they played one
time I forget who it was my B mark paren
toe I forget who it was who was the DJ
was Santa yeah
who's saying that this look this is not
my head mean actually might have been
coz it might not have been bcn anyway
when whoever the DJ was it was a rock
station and they were like look this
isn't rock but it's [ __ ] good they
didn't say [ __ ] good that's really
good and that's what we're playing at
they played Michael Jackson and I
remember thinking wow this is so crazy
they're gonna play a Michael Jackson
song but it was really good yeah
and so you're like okay I'll take it you
know I still it's funny
remember that because I still remember
the one morning brushing my teeth and
they're like oh we're playing this new
band the police is song rocks and I
thought it was like this reggae band
until I saw a picture
rest in peace Ric Ocasek I now asked him
today Ric Ocasek that cars that's a
bummer that was a bummer those guys are
so the cars is one of those bands where
whenever you don't know what to listen
to he can always listen to the cars so
many good songs and it's so good yeah he
was such an interesting guy too so it's
a an oddity yeah tall thank you with the
sunglasses and the supermodel and every
song is awesome you know there he was
brilliant that's a bummer man that's a
bummer
and he was cool too because I remember
when he produced the Bad Brains record
rock for light and I was like Ric Ocasek
he's hipper than I thought I just took
yeah so like news movies wise movie wise
like when you were a kid do you in
horror films back then I was into
everything but I loved that for sure but
I like I don't even know if we I we
definitely didn't call him horror movies
we thought everything everything was a
monster movie this monster movie like
that's just what we call because it was
always like you know we had creature
double feature on channel 56 do you
remember that sure yeah well that was
like the every weekend [ __ ] its destroy
all monsters and you know whatever yeah
so that was yeah so big time that ruled
our world so watching them back then
that's when you got the idea well it got
the idea that I loved it I wanted to do
it but it was oh it was the idea like
yeah I want to be an astronaut too like
it didn't seem like an idea that was
ever gonna happen he's just something
that you were really into yeah and it's
really funny to this funny the weird
things because at one time in high
school me and my friends filmed a sequel
to Escape from New York
the John Carpenter film I don't know I'm
getting better and then to be like you
know however mint 20 years later that I
remade a John Carpenter film Halloween
was just so bizarre I guess I've been
thinking about it for a long time but
you know that is kind of crazy it's
weird yeah it's weird [ __ ] like that
well when your first actual film films
well mm 4 mm mm yeah because the way it
went down was this is a funny story too
I made my first movie house 1000 corpses
at Universal Studios and it was 2000 it
could have been even the tail into 1999
I'm not sure they won't resent notes mm
I had a wrap gift somebody gave me and
they put a date I was like mm so I made
the movie with Universal Studios and
once they screened it we had our test
screening which I thought went I thought
went great and well I know that the head
of Universal at the time came up and was
like we have to talk tomorrow and that
was not a good tone that wasn't it
you're so great we want to give you a 5
picture deal tone of voice so the next
day they dumped the movie and you know
just basically booted us out and then I
blows the conversation they were like we
basically this is unreleasable I don't
remember word for word but that was the
conversation in a nutshell but at the
time too you figured there was no horror
coming out of Universal they were making
like The Flintstones movie and that was
not the image they wanted this really
vile sort of backwoods hillbilly murder
fest where there's and the bad people
win essentially I mean horror films were
sort of like not even a commercial thing
at that point in a way so then which is
funny now if you go to Universal Studios
Hollywood
Orlando there's a huge house of a
thousand Corpses thing event going on in
both theme parks that's a lair I was
there for the old grand opening like
that's funny like it's like I get fired
from here and now you know 20 years
later it's a theme park attraction in
the exact place I got fired for him Wow
which is so weird what was the
conversation like before you decided to
do that film I mean how did how did they
let you do it
I don't you know I'd again I think
getting to make a movie for Universal
Studios was such an amazing experience
but I think I was too naive to
understand what was happening it'd be
like you did one set of comes lagata put
you on tour George Carter like cool I
guess it's the way it happens man
you know it's after like wow I didn't
really appreciate just went down did it
not that I was took it for granted but I
had I had met with someone at the theme
park about doing a haunted maze during
their horror Halloween Horror Nights
based on my album and then sort of by
being in the offices was meeting meeting
people and having just meetings about
stuff or I just didn't want to leave
once I got in the studio I just loved
being there even though I had no
business being there
and somehow I remember being in the guy
his name was Kevin Mischer his office
pitching him a movie I didn't have a
pitch for I had a title but not nothing
else and somehow it progressed from
there I was like really I told them kind
of a cool title with a completely
half-assed idea that was making up as I
was talking to remember I was weird I
don't even I I can't remember it well
because it after the fact I'm like how
did this happen I don't remember this is
like your story's like the anti ambition
store it's like the anti preparation
story exactly for successful nonetheless
yeah I guess the the goal is just be
vague with people you don't care and I
had that attitude too I remember once
the movie was rolling I was like this is
what I want to cast and this is exactly
what I want to do and if you guys don't
want to do it that's cool let's just not
work together and they did it Wow
like that's my part right and I we shot
it on the universal back lot we were
like right there like doing the whole
thing and big production and it was
weird Wow
when when it wrapped like final day
final scene and that's a wrap
were you like what the [ __ ] just
happened well the funny thing is like
after we wrapped the first time we had a
little test screening within the studio
like friends like oh we should probably
punch up the ending so they gave me like
they gave me more money to reshoot the
ending that I actually made my newest
movie with it was like money was nothing
like you know there's throwing money
around like it was like nothing else I
hung my cousins and saying we were
building these giant sets Jonah's crazy
stuff
it was after that that you know the
problem started but I don't I wish I
could remember these things better it's
weird that I don't but what attracted
you to this ultra violent psychopath
like outcasts murderous style of movie
that you do because you have like these
almost like mutant society psycho murder
people that you know but people [ __ ]
love it man I've always dug like
outsider mentality like anything that
involved like out I think it started as
a kid as a kid because like a lot of
people can relate this I didn't feel
like I fit in like I was like weird I
didn't fit in I didn't get like what
were the cool shoes to wear or the right
freakin Izod sure I didn't understand I
wasn't trying to be you know no one's
trying to be weird and like oh yeah I
want to be weird and hide away cuz I'm
weird no it's like I don't understand
and I think when I would watch new
monster movies the monster was always
that mentality like King Kong's like hey
man I'm just trying to get along why is
everyone shooting at me in
Frankenstein's like hey I was just born
yesterday why you're trying to kill me
like and I think as a weird kid you
relate to the monster
so as life went on and you know the I
would always relate to the outsider then
I would always relate to movies like
taxi driver Bonnie and Clyde and yeah
and Travis Bickle you know he's the
[ __ ] man you know and I would always
be like anything anti-society Anthea
[ __ ] you [ __ ] everything that's normal
right like revenge yeah I was just into
it and I felt real similar when I was a
kid I was always in the monster movies I
was always into something that just just
tore all the normal people apart and
just ripped apart all the conceived
notions of what everybody thought was
gonna happen and then around the end
towards the end of high school when I
discovered punk rock you figure out
there's an entire form of music where
they're just like go [ __ ] yourself yeah
that's what we're here I was like I'm in
and so many other people as well yeah
and it's just like it just it flips your
whole idea of what life is and then when
I moved to New York I was like wow this
entire city of people don't give a [ __ ]
yeah that's where they come yeah nobody
gives a [ __ ] about anything here it's
it's amazing how your movies resonate
with people like - like in a fanatical
way like the read the comments on just a
trailer for three from hell
you know just people are so [ __ ]
pumped yeah it's it's great and I mean
it's been it's been a long journey
because like when my first movie came
out I think every review basically said
something along lines of worst movie
ever made I hate this movie and now
people do look that's your best movie
you know like you've been choosing the
river soon so it's just weird how it
same with white zombie when our first
Geffen he still remember this our first
Geffen record came out I saw the first
review it was this magazine alternative
press who two years ago gave me this
Lifetime Achievement Award and I had to
read the review while accepting what the
review said this is the worst band ever
and it said this is the worst band ever
ignore this band yeah so there was
something and you know there must have
been something your contacts the person
who wrote that now I didn't hide back
then I was just like I mean like I felt
like maybe a few years later who was I I
used to be upset by reviews until I saw
who wrote them mmm yeah you know yeah
that's a lot of critics or critics cuz
they really wanted to be writers they
just don't have a lot to contribute and
so they just [ __ ] on things and it's
just like you as a when you're young and
you're new and you're reading you think
that the guys writing it frightening all
badass you like oh this dude must look
like Lemmy he must be this hard-ass guy
you know I mean you see I like that guy
wrote it off [ __ ] him you [ __ ] everyone
else whoever writes I do you think again
I don't give a [ __ ] yeah but the thing
is about music is it's so subjective and
you know someone who grew up wearing the
right Izod shirts hanging with the cool
crowd they're not gonna it's your musics
not gonna resonate with them the sound
way it's gonna be with other people that
felt like they were Outsiders I mean I
can only do what I do and I don't know
what would be popular
I don't understand popular culture in a
way because when people are like gushing
over something a movie or something I
say go I hated that movie I know it made
500 million dollars and it's everyone's
favorite movie I go I could barely sit
through it yeah there's a lot of those
being made same with music like I'd be
like I love The Velvet Underground it
was like but what about and they'll name
something like you know I don't want a
minute - anybody but something so
popular that makes me want to kill
myself
yeah that literally it's sickening do
you like any films today is there
anything that yeah and I you know I mean
what kind of [ __ ] do you enjoy i watch
every everything i mean i whenever
there's something that's more like
smaller movies i really like like i was
thinking about the other day about this
time in the 90s where like you got
movies like Napoleon Dynamite and
American Splendor which is how you ever
see that we yes I thought Paul Giamatti
of happy cars is like the greatest movie
ever made in a gross world does early
tear you so I got films like that's
where I kind of my head was that just
weird movies like that yeah
it's some like Napoleon Dynamite to this
day is one of the greatest comedies of
all time as soon as that movie started
in the credits were food I was like this
is like the greatest thing I've seen in
a theater in like 20 years what is going
on here well it's I just don't
understand why they never made a second
one
I don't know that didn't make any sense
to me I'm like this is a [ __ ]
franchise waiting to happen
like him and the other dude the who's
the guy who played his was his uncle
uncle Rico yeah I mean the [ __ ] guy
was amazing they were so like over the
top but believable like everything about
it when he's feeding Tina
[Laughter]
it just doesn't see much I just it
doesn't seem like he could miss I loved
that movie
yeah well I could see them doing it now
yeah but years later he tried to do that
with Dumb and Dumber remember that yeah
did it way way way too late yeah that's
him carries like 15 ever it's like this
is just weird
you're not young anymore yeah you can't
be a buffoon that's Howard lightning in
a bottle to recreate yeah dummer yeah
right right right it's like stepbrothers
certain movies that just right you got
to kind of leave them alone
I remember seeing stepbrother it sounds
like is it my imagination is every
single [ __ ] thing in this movie
hilarious
well those two just like together you
know Talladega Nights
just amazing and Talladega Nights I love
when a comedies made well yeah so often
they're not yes you know that's what I
liked about the hangover if you turn the
sound off you just looked at it it's a
really good-looking well-made film and
then you turn on the sound you realize
it's hilarious but so many comedies are
just so shitty what's that new Seth
Rogen produced film with kids the good
boys yeah yeah I didn't see this oh my
[ __ ] wife said it was amazing she
said it was like like piss your pants
laughs oh really yeah that's good I got
it I need to go see it
you don't even see I like he has like a
live-action like South Park that's a
good way to describe you see it yeah
yeah yeah because it's r-rated yeah Seth
Rogen can't mess he's hilarious now when
you were a kid like you liked all kinds
of stuff but did you think if you wanted
to make films that you would be making
the kind of films that you're making now
these like butchers well I guess since
the first thing I made was that and I
can't I was into it I mean I liked
because what happened to was when I
moved to Manhattan in like 1982 or
something I discovered when when New
York City was all second run theaters
and double features so I could finally
see the laundry list of films I'd never
been able to see I remember the first
time I liked 8th Street Playhouse was a
good example where first time I saw it
Texas Chainsaw Massacre was on a double
bill with Jimmy plays Berkeley the Jimi
Hendrix movie was a double bill but
double bills yeah and I would go see
like oh my god Ilsa she-wolf so the SS
is playing with faster pussycat oh my
god this and I could because I could
never see him because there was no VHS
yet or I was so new that those movies
weren't around that I just had books and
I was just staring at books cuz back in
the day you know that's kinda because
with the this new movie three from hell
you know it's playing on about a
thousand screens so it's not like
everywhere like you can't walk two feet
and it's on five screens and people
fifteen minute drive from my house I was
like I would literally drive for five
hours as a kid if there was a movie I
wanted to see it didn't matter I'd ride
my one time I rode before I could drive
I rode my bike for like three hours to
see night living-dead at a midnight
screening cuz I'm gonna see this no
matter what
cuz if you didn't see it was just gonna
evaporate that's one of the things I
love about people from Canada Canada
they drive everywhere like you know
friends in Alberta they'll drive seven
hours to go see something yeah cuz
that's what you have to do yeah good
morning and that's your day you're
driving somewhere and when I was younger
that was like part of the fun I didn't
care
yeah that's an adventure so the concerts
thirty hours away so yeah
did you study or you have you watched a
lot of like really old horror yeah I
mean I watch sometimes I feel like I'm
searching for things to watch because I
would try to watch literally everything
and I want to own everything so I have
like a vault at home that has you know
twenty thousand movies in it because I
never if somebody mentions something I
don't know what it is like [ __ ] and I
like write it down I immediately have to
go like investigate it so when they say
a vault like an actual vault like a bank
no I just thought of it's just a room
that I built that just is nothing but
like a movie library because I want to
own everything so you have a physical
copy of all these yeah what format do
you put them in well now they're DVD I
mean they were laser discs and VHS and
then I started trading because what
happens now it's great that everything's
digital but if you go to iTunes 99% of
the things I want to see aren't there
mmm because they're not you know so you
can do that thing now that was nice on
Amazon where you can they will burn the
movie on CD to own because it'll be like
weird movies like I was spent forever
trying to find I mean I got it many
years ago but like there was a movie
called dirty little Billy with Michael J
Paulette as Billy the Kid little bit
yeah this is amazing movie from the 70s
and finally you can get it like they'll
you know they or it's made to order CDs
I mean I DVDs on Amazon and stuff so
when I was a kid I was gigantically in
horror films and I used to read Fangoria
time and I remember they were
into these there were slasher movies
from like I guess like the 60s that had
never heard of that were like ultra
gorefest movies yeah I God trying to
remember who was the director but there
was a guy who was famous for other
Herschell Gordon Lewis is that what you
think thousand maniacs and blood fees
yeah yes yes like that stuff I never was
exposed to that now I've still this day
I've never seen one of those films but
the magazines were covered with like
people with axes and yeah because things
would play it at the drive-in and then
go away yeah you know that was layout
that's how I felt when the first time
when I loved when 40 strike second
Street in New York was the real 40
seconds right and I remember so funny my
friend my roommate back then we'd always
go to 42nd Street to see movies could be
like Cannibal Holocaust I would just see
the poster what the [ __ ] is cannibal ha
ha
and you'll see this Italian cannibal
movie go this is literally the most
Viking not believe another human made
this movie right blows your mind but
where every time I went to 42nd Street I
saw a really bad incident happen like
you could not go there like would be
like waiting line and like oh let's go
get some french fries before the movie
to guys to start fighting at McDonald's
one guy would just pummel the other guy
that'd be blood everywhere I go it
happened next time ago we'd see guy
stabbed another guy in the theater while
watching there it is like literally I'd
never went there once and even right
till I was recording my album before I
moved I remember walking to the studio
which was like maybe forty third and
there was a dead body lying there and
they just found him and they were just
starting to put the sheet so I actually
didn't see the violin act but I saw but
he didn't care like New York it was like
New York when I moved to New York and 82
still seemed like you know taxi-driver
New York
yeah well that was when it was it was
coming from Haverhill Wilding West so
exciting cuz Haverhill so boring in
comparison it couldn't be more boring if
its goal is to be boring it's gold medal
yeah I remember
Haverhill was so bad that when we were
kids I remember what I don't forget
maybe this is maybe the Bison we're on
the Bicentennial I think they were
trying to drive business because Main
Street
we can't even blame Walmart back then
was dead there was nothing there which
is a ghost town you know like they just
put all these banners up Haverhill the
all-american city but it was less the
catchphrase is gonna matter make people
open businesses so bad time to sell
flags yeah exactly
yeah I went to New York City for the
first time in the 80s as well I'm trying
to remember what year it was it was like
somewhere probably around 82 or 83 and
when we were in in the city driving
around I remember thinking like this is
the craziest [ __ ] place I've ever
been in my life
the buildings were so big it didn't make
sense pulling up to it
I remember we drove up on the West Side
Highway and you see the city coming up
in the disciplic see the buildings get
larger and larger as you get closer it's
mental didn't seem real I remember being
on the sidewalk now this is coming from
a place where a sidewalk means there's
literally no other person on the
sidewalk as far as you can see right and
they were standing on the sidewalk and
must have been uptown somewhere it was
like you couldn't move with people it's
like what is happening right I've never
seen like this is how it is all the time
like I live in the street in Haverhill
like a car drive drove down it like once
a day and it was probably your dad
coming home from work like there was
just nothing if you could have you view
out of Time Machine though and you went
from 1982 and you said hey what do you
think it's gonna look like in 2019 he'd
be like [ __ ] man it's gonna be Mad Max
yeah like did it be [ __ ] cars driving
with black smoke coming out of them
people shooting people right on the
street it's gonna be though it's gonna
get worse it's not gonna get better yeah
the only thing I remember right towards
my end of being there there was that
Tompkins Square you know downtown and
that was where it's just like wherever
homeless people lived it was Alphabet
City it was like the worst well hey wait
on the back when I first moved here like
the first night I was there this sounds
like I'm making it up and I'm not the
first night I was there the dorm that I
was in with all my roommates over looked
Union Square Park which is like needle
Park you just went there to buy dope and
that was it there was now you go there
first because it's a farmers market it's
beautiful
and I heard this guy screaming and
screaming and screaming
as Christ was going on because of like a
hundred degrees and of course there's no
air conditioning I look out the window
and I watched these cops beat up this
guy I was like and then they dragged him
down to the subway and the next day all
these cops showed up at the dorms and it
was that it was this guy Michael Stewart
it became a really famous case he was
they called him a graffiti artist and he
had been beat to death by the cops and
me and all my roommates saw it and the
next day they came and took our
statement and we all had to testify in
front of the grand jury this is my first
day out of Haverhill we I witnessed a
murder but again it's like the same
thing with like my deal at Universal I
was like - not even weird to really
comprehend because he bumped like things
are happening I'm so jaded it didn't
disturb me or seem like I don't know I
don't know throwing me but I am
desensitized by all the violence I've
witnessed as a as a child I guess well
that would you see more violence before
that
well there's one famous thing I remember
as a kid besought there's two famous
things I just don't know when I was a
kid the family business that my mom came
from was like carnivals like you ever
see that movie carny
yeah with Gary Busey yeah that's exactly
the life as a kid that I remember when I
saw the movie I was like this is this is
what this was our life we were as well
that makes sense
yeah attraction you have these Drifters
yeah I was always what I was surrounded
by so that was the thing I remember as a
kid except and when it was around 1970s
everything because I remember kiss love
gonna just came out talked about it and
the family work that my mom and dad and
we my brother had to work and sell food
and stuff and I hated I used we used to
have to dip the candy apples and handle
with people and they've healed now but I
all my head burns all over my hands cuz
the apple candy would be so hot it would
drip on my hand and burn my hands anyway
I digress
but one night there was the gambling
tents which were all rigged of course
and someone had some guide getting
fleeced for all of his money and came
back and lit the tent on fire and then
suddenly [ __ ] hit the fan everybody that
me and my little brother had been around
all the time it's like boom all these
guns start coming out and you start
hearing guns popping up and then the
tents just went like nothing was fired
for so everything's on fire it's
complete chaos and I was probably in
fifth grade my brother was probably in
second grade everybody screaming to run
around and my and this guy was like that
I don't remember his name but he worked
there he was like hey you guys should
come over here and before he finished a
sense somebody ran up and hit him in the
face with a hammer and broke his whole
face open it was just gushing blood and
we're like and then eventually my
parents got us in the car and we left
which was that was my parent my mom's
like we're done this is we're not doing
this anymore does last time we ever did
wow what a great way to go out though
but the best was going to school on
September like what did you do this
summer and that was my story Wow
we didn't go to Cape Camp Zuppa sake we
we were in a carnival riot what was the
gambling tent like what kind of games
are they Riggin I don't know I mean
everything's rigged like anything from
and it's even a great scene in Kearney
where I'm the friend of mine who's an
Elan my moves meg Foster plays when
she's holding all the long strands of
rope and Joanie fought she's trained
rode if I was like you pull the rope and
it's connected to a prize or I or like
and everything's rigged like the the
weighted lead milk bottles you're
supposed to knock down the softball I
mean everything's rigged I mean certain
ways you know how to cheat them so that
when the guys shown how to do it like
it's so easy just throw it like this but
it's a certain way you can throw it work
but otherwise woman I would never be in
the gambling tents because they were
actually gambling we were like a little
tiny kids but it was we probably
roulette wheels I'm guessing mmm things
like that
so it you know the guys spins it and
break it something his foot and it never
stops on the number that the guys got
all of his money on cuz he let him win a
bunch times or something so when the
fire broke out and people started
shooting was shooting at who I don't
know what was going just Kate I just
yeah we're little kids like you don't
really comprehending this going on only
fourth or fifth grade just like that
guys now got a gun I hear gunshots
everything's on fire there's smoke
people screaming this guy's now
gushing brains out of the front of his
head and so [ __ ] I said there were two
stories that was oh the second story the
second story I kind of put in this the
new movie three from hell
this was like when I was in high school
I was in the backyard rehearsing with my
two friends or a band or whatever and we
heard this screaming it was a bright
sunny day that seemed like a David Lynch
movie suburbia and this fat naked guy
was running down the street covered in
blood even stabbed a whole bunch of
times
like people are mowing their lawns and
looking at and I just remember a bloody
naked guy running down the street
screaming like a weird scream people
scream weird when they get stabbed and
um so I put some like that movie but it
just yeah what happened to him I don't
know it was like granite he was knocking
and again I was like oh weird and I just
went back and we continued rehearsing
whoa like again
that must have flavored the music a
little bit yeah I don't know that it's
like I should be I should be really
bothered by things like that but I'm not
yeah well I mean there's a thing that
happens when you see too much it's one
of the reasons why cops and soldiers
have some of the oddest sense of humor I
could see that yeah they've just seen
too many bodies they've seen yeah yeah I
mean imagine the guys that have to come
scrape up all the stuff off the road and
load in the bag so yeah yeah I mean
after you know yeah but yeah that was
the life I remember I remember my mom's
brother he would always uh didn't always
use but sometimes he was a biker so he'd
come over to the house and he had a
chopper with iron crosses on and he kind
of looked at let me the big mustache and
I was like this guy that's like drivers
around the neighborhood so everyone can
see us you know that stuff so when you
were saying that you collect the films
and you have films did you do go back to
like the really old ones like Nosferatu
oh yeah I love silent movies and now
they're easier to get because I always
loved lon chaney with so many of the
hard to get I was showing my kids lon
chaney two nights ago what movie did
well I was showing them the the original
Wolfman and I was showing them Jekyll
and Hyde I was showing him some of the
Lon Chaney jr. well
Wolffe dad yes and like phantom of the
opera' enemies back in noah's day
jacqueline hide as well that was long
cheney right no Frederick March
oh well it depends what there's the John
Barrymore silent jekyll-and-hyde but
your pregnancy the Frederic March one is
great it's so perverted the prostitutes
and stuff isn't that the one you showed
your kids like from the 34 short of the
30s that was a poor much born well
there's the boring one with Spencer
Tracy is boring and just compared to the
other one the other ones all because
anything that's sort of like the
pre-code stuff is really we watched an
upbeat the beginning of the Spencer
Tracy one because it was so strange they
there there's actually when you know on
iTunes you can watch a preview but it's
not really a preview when it's old films
because they didn't have yeah previews
back then so it's just al scene and it's
a scene when he's becoming mr. Hyde but
he doesn't look any different
yeah he just looks a little meaner you
know the Frederic March one is one of
the best ones they ever made it's so
good but lone Cheney was like it was
Phantom of the Opera which is a really
interesting one because he he liked that
he put on some really painful makeup for
that I mean he just invented everything
yeah he'd the things he'd do I mean I
don't know how much the stories have
been exaggerated by publicity
departments over the years but yeah I
mean it's just incredible and movies
like the unknown or the unholy 3 mm-hmm
like you can get everything now forever
I was like I'm positive I'll see these
movies for a long time I don't do it
anymore but I used to collect vintage
movie posters and that's what I would go
after the the Lon Chaney's silent movie
posters because a lot of times I feel
that there's only one of these in
existence and then I realize I'm
spending too much money on things those
old films you know when I'm trying to
show them to my kids I was just trying
to we were we're going from the 20s to
the 30s there's a movie that's the
original horror film that have found
that was 1920 it's actually 2 years over
the Nosferatu
it was dr. something dr. Caligari
Caligari
yeah that's a good yeah we watched a
little bit of that too but I just wanted
to show them how weird it is like the
progression of film particularly scary
films because when my kids were real
little I
wife was out of town and I said do you
guys want to watch a scary movie that's
not really scary they were nervous how
old are they
that's a time I think they were five and
three or maybe six and for someone we
started throwing down the test do you
want to watch it but I knew it wasn't
gonna be really scary so I put on the
original King Kong from blue is that
like 30 33 I think and we were laughs
and I was like let me tell you something
we're gonna watch this and it's so fake
it looks so dumb I go we're gonna we're
gonna laugh and so we're cuddled up on
the couch they were nervous and yeah
then once they saw the thing like that's
it that's the monster I was like let me
tell you something kid in 1933 this was
scary for people they really thought
this is realistic they thought this was
amazing do you ever have that moment
you'll watch something like say I do
this like Frankenstein like you're
seeing it so many times it's hard to
watch it like you've never seen it
before but sometimes I'll be watching
something and there'll be a scene where
like Frankenstein is killing Fritz and
there's no music and he's just screaming
I was like this must have [ __ ] been
so intense because no one had seen
anything like this they're watching this
yeah creature who they don't understand
the makeup because no one knew who I was
done like especially because he kind of
the first appearance of Karloff is
Franklin he kind of backs in and turns
and I heads flat yes oh and the Jack
Pierce makeup is so incredible that I
was just like people must have been like
running for the door pull up a picture
of what Boris Karloff looked like in
that movie I haven't seen that in
forever but I'm so good it was so good I
mean in the also it's so difficult for
us to understand perspective like to put
yourself in their place back then yeah
look at that
yeah lighting was incredible now we're
used to seeing that it's so iconic that
like or that it becomes like but if
you'd never I mean never seen anything
like that before I mean I guess going
back to always said a second ago like
Lon Chaney and Phantom of the Opera and
his quasi motor you kind of LaBolt
something but that must have just been
like [ __ ] chaos for a battery that's
so crazy the posts on his neck do you
remember when they did a remake with
DeNiro I do I don't remember it movie
very good I don't
neither but I remember of being
terrifying looking like that yeah he was
updated yeah he looked cool in that yeah
it's a tough one though with those
movies because they got it so right the
first time
yeah and the performance is alike when I
watch like I I really like Lugosi in
Dracula and when you watch it I always
feel like he's like Brando of that time
because everyone else is like talking
like yeah well like like they're still
getting vodka bill and they're way over
the top and then too much and he's like
this in this doing this thing yeah but
sometimes you're like you can almost
can't understand him because of his
accent like wow he's like in this whole
weird head trip and they're like doing
play hey listen buddy you know like the
way they're talking yeah and that's why
nobody can remember David manners who
got paid 10 times with a go see but but
Lugosi is like this iconic thing like
Marilyn Monroe I mean that this was so
out of time with so special what they
were doing yeah even in when in the film
there's a scene where the woman had been
bit and it's like what's wrong what's
going on
he's so corny and over-the-top and in
that you know the style of that era but
Lugosi is on another level and the and
like everybody like a lot of those
actors then seem very much like they
were in the closet and they were trying
to like play with the woman and Lugosi
has that vibe like I'm gonna [ __ ]
everything on this set before I leave
this movie you know he just reeks of
like I'm from I'm Hungarian and I'm
gonna nail every actress in this film
yeah and he's a [ __ ] powerful vampire
yeah bought into it like yeah in the
role he was yeah in the headspace and a
lot of those movies and other good ones
like the black cat we're like the same
guy was in the Dracula's and he's so
like swishing over the top and Lugosi
and Karloff together are so intense it's
like this two different movies going on
this weird Hollywood and this weird
thing these other guys are doing man
it's like Brando in Apocalypse Now like
he's making a whole different movie yes
yeah you know it's cool to just go back
in time and see the progression of
horror to go from those films like I
still think Nosferatu to this day is one
of the coolest vampires ever it's so
incredible there was no there was no
of benchmark yeah for him right I mean
and he looked so [ __ ] weird with the
long fingers and yeah creepy and the way
he would rise remember when they had him
on a boy I just was like straight it
looks incredible and I still and I love
them
the Hertzog remake with Klaus Kinski oh
that's right so amazing yeah and
Kinski's so like he's so perfect because
he's such another crazy actor that yes
reeks of crazy right off the screen yes
yes yeah it's just hard to do a good
monster movie these days I mean I'm a
gigantic Rick Baker fan obviously yeah
he's coming on here to I was a oh yeah
his new book looks amazing yeah I'm so
excited I'm getting him to promote that
but I'm just I was when I was a kid I
wanted to be a makeup artist it was
really I wanted to do yeah so I studied
Rick Baker and I studied you know the
the early lon chaney days like we were
talking about and I just love
prosthetics in like Star Wars and Chile
which by the way I went to the Star Wars
attraction yesterday oh you did is you
man
it's the [ __ ] ooh that [ __ ] Star Wars
ride the ride is incredible man it
simulated though right yes I I won't
throw up but I'll feel like I want to
for the rest of the day it's awesome
it's awesome so Mike my kids we're
steering they got a chance to steer that
they were the pilots and you slamming
into [ __ ] doesn't have to coordinate
one goes up one goes down left and right
so up and down is one kid and left and
right yeah they're next to each other in
the cockpit are they separate like next
to each other
Hahnemann close but they're like
asteroids when they're hitting [ __ ] but
but uh just the ride is [ __ ]
incredible I mean you could see there's
so much money poured into there and
apparently there's a bunch of other ones
that are there they're in the process of
developing - oh really
but I loved those movies and a big part
of it was like like the cantina scene if
you if you went to that now you'd be
like oh my god it's obviously a mask oh
yeah like their faces really like that
weird weird
yeah no but they're not moving yeah
laughter that data but back down I was
like this is amazing oh my god I can so
clearly seeing that remember seeing that
movie for the first time because I was
like it like you come out of I remember
coming out and be like shell-shocked
like everything I thought about
everything just changed yeah it's like
I'll be the second it's another movie
that's so hard to put in perspective
I've watched it with my kids now and
it's like you gotta bring them back to
the 1970s and this movie came out you
don't get it like back then this was
[ __ ] insane how good it was yeah
people would want me I watched it like I
think we had like little competitions
with our friends to see who could watch
it the most amount of times I think I
saw it like 13 times yes I mean it's
crazy
and I someone gave me a laser not a
laser for a blu-ray of the original
before Lucas did all the extra stuff and
ruined it somehow they had cut together
somebody went to all the trouble of
getting like a Japanese lasers and they
cut together a blu-ray of exactly the
movie as it was in 1977 what did you do
differently in the new version enhance
some of the special effects he added
that scene with the digital you know
Jabba the Hutt and just like they'll be
like the tauntaun that's like what
there's just little robots and [ __ ]
everywhere that wasn't there in the
original I did and now what seems so
badass for effects and whatever was 2000
now looks super bad stuff from 77 still
that's why I always want to like you
watch 2001 you go like how can this
still look better than everything yeah
these are literally models shot in 1968
or some book you prick knew the
limitations of the visual format and so
he he shot things in a way where he
didn't he wasn't willing to compromise
the way something looked to show you
something that like like sort of like
the King Kong animation like that's as
best they could do back then yeah but
Kubrick figured workarounds they I just
read this new book that came out well
maybe six months ago that's all about
the making of 2001 and it's the book is
so detailed I wish you could remember
the title of and it's amazing the amount
of time like it's stuff you take for
granted out just how they had to make
the digital readouts on the computer
screens mmm because that stuff did not
exist it
so the amount of time that went into
just simple background things that
nobody cares about it is just
mind-blowing
just the weightlessness scenes and how
they did all that stuff which still look
amazing
no it's still an incredible movie and
it's also a time capsule right it's like
it's one of those films that it's great
but it's also great and of time caps
yeah it's I love it because um I love
all of his movies for the same reason
because they take over the viewer like
most movies they're like you watch it
and it's doing what the movie thinks
will make you happy whereas Kubrick's
doing stuff like well this is what it
would be like to be in space yeah this
is the pace it's gonna unfold that yeah
like which is painfully slow at times
well you can't get away with that today
no because people are too the rolled up
they don't have the attention span I
don't think and same thing with Barry
Lyndon her clockwork orange' doesn't
matter what movie it is his - The
Shining yes
like now someone made the shine and go
it's great you got to cut the first hour
out of it you know we're gonna start it
with the Red Rum scene ya know the
opening shot would be and then go three
hours
yeah yeah they would do that they would
go three months earlier you know they
would do that it's um it's it's cool to
see though like those films they did
what they could do with what was
available whereas with now the problem
with CGI is they use it and they overuse
it and I think that I don't I don't I
haven't CGI can be phenomenal for sure
but it's a tool and it's turned into a
crutch and I see it with actors like you
see actors a lot of time and I feel bad
for the actors you sue the actors there
you go I know these guys are great but
they're awful in this movie because I
didn't train to stand in a warehouse
that's green and pretend to look at
stuff yeah right so they really like
when you watch The Phantom Menace you go
why does it suddenly seem like Liam
Neeson can't act right because he's like
they're like look at that dot on the
wall I mean and you know these guys are
incredible actors I was talking about
somebody wants to kid those in my movie
was in all the Spy Kids movies and he
said it was so hard because they'd be on
a green screen
you're looking at that we're not sure
what you're looking at but just stare at
that dot and react you so what is it
yeah is it a dragon or is it my mom what
am i reacting to like we haven't figured
it out yet and he said he was always in
a constant state of confusion as to what
he was reacting to well it's hard to
when you go back and you look at some of
them like you know what movie got it
right that sort of didn't get enough
respect in its time but in in in time
like as time passed it's become more
respected as starship troopers yeah I
know I don't remember that movie that
well it's a you know it's all you're
gonna kill her we're slugs
Oh like they like removing major Dan's
legs I mean that's like when see Jesus I
thought oh [ __ ] they found a guy with no
legs he's a great actor because I don't
know Gary Sinise was back how about the
ping-pong scene yeah a lot of [ __ ] yeah
the was getting uh with with monster
movies though it's um Pat McGee he's the
guy who did that
werewolf the one that's out there yeah
he'll make them for you like he makes
power and we had this conversation about
it we were saying that you can see CGI
and even if it's awesome your brain
knows it's CGI that's funny they I have
that same thought that it's something
subliminally your brain knows it's all
fake yes like Godzilla where's like yeah
like Godzilla like when you know it's a
guy in a rubber suit crushing things
like well if you watch the original one
wouldn't like when they cut in Raymond
Burr there's something so dark and
fucked-up about them yes because
everything's that's real fire there's
actually three dimensional objects
blowing up but when it's so big and fake
like I always say like what's scarier a
giant CG creature that you know you will
never see or like a maniac with a
pillowcase over his head holding an axe
coming at you like your brain goes that
could happen I get it yes yes things
like well that's I'm not gonna that's
like Roger Rabbit that's not gonna
happen you know it's not it might be
cool there might be but it's not like
one of the scariest horror movies of all
time is alien yeah and in the first few
encounters they have with the creature
you don't even see the damn thing
because it's you couldn't show it that
much like the you know like the
shark and jaws but when you see it it's
like it's actually there yeah you can
feel that its jaws are right in front of
Sigourney Weaver's face yeah it's not
like she's looking at nothing in her eye
lines a little off because it's a you
know tennis ball and a stick she's
looking at there's something about it
really happening in the space that I
think people can feel it and Sigourney
Weaver is surprising Sigourney Weaver an
alien is the greatest female action hero
star ever because you bought it hook
line and sinker she was a scientist she
wasn't supposed to be this heroine
that's out there just [ __ ] things up
and killing everybody and she wasn't
supposed to be super hot and sexy and
young but she was hot enough because she
became tough and it made her but like
like the whole I remember when alien
came out it was kind of like when the
thing came out and all the reviews were
bad if you remember really yeah I mean
the Bruce are everything a bad when you
go back a little oh these there's no
redeemable characters are there all
cartoon keys cardboard characters they
rip everything apart but but like it's
like Harry Dean Stanton Yaphet Kotto is
on a every great character actor doing
great roles but it was like now if they
remade that'd be like everybody reviews
but that's the thing the reviews never
mean anything that just like so crazy
the first was it Harry Dean Stanton that
saw it the first time who was it this
saw it the first time where they could
they climbed down into the they climbed
down the stairs and it's it's right
there
I don't see it for like a second but it
was a physical thing but the point is it
was an actual guy in a suit
yeah and you knew by the way it was
moving that it was an actual guy right
in front of and it took up three
dimensional space in real life yeah you
could feel it you give yes and you know
yeah I mean just like when the chest
first thing yeah it's a it it's actually
I can bizarre or an American Werewolf in
London say exactly you see brief
glimpses of this thing like really quick
like one frame one second of it you know
and then at the end of it you you see it
even when they merge they kill it in the
hallway or in the alleyway yeah that's
you know you only see it for a couple
seconds when when it stares at her and
then they gunned it down yeah that was
like the heyday for effects every
I know who does effects it was like the
thing American Werewolf in London or a
howling whatever and Fangoria when that
started he started really getting
articles and stuff and like labo teen
and Rick Baker became my rock stars to
the horror nerds
well the Rick Baker scene when he
transforms into the werewolf in the
chicks apartment we have the in the
nurse's apartment for the first time and
he's like I'm [ __ ] and it's like
bright it's a great apartment that's
what makes it weird ass in the hand
stretch [ __ ] wild man to this day
weird just and then he tried to kind of
recreate like the actual makeup style
werewolf with the Wolfman with Benicio
del Toro yeah but it just wasn't there
the movie wasn't there just wasn't
wasn't quite good enough but there's one
[ __ ] badass scene where it becomes the
Wolfman when they're in the insane
asylum doing tests on them you remember
that film I don't remember that film
that much I remember I don't I hate
saying things cuz this was my thought at
the time I remember watching it thinking
Benicio del Toro seems like he doesn't
want to be in this movie
which is such a stupid thing for me to
say because I don't know what the [ __ ]
he wants it was I think he's a brilliant
actor and I really like watch it but it
just had that feeling like I don't know
what it was and I I've talked to people
connected with that movie and I don't
think it was a great experience for
people for some reason maybe there's a
lot of meddling probably a lot of
meddling is that something that's a
difficult thing to manage or do you not
have to deal with that anymore I had to
deal with that a lot when I made the two
Halloween movies on Steam company
because they're this gigantic franchise
well there was weird meddling it was
just like kind of psychotic meddling how
so just weird like like my phone was
ringing all the time when I'm on set
working and it'd be like we think it
should be this I'm like why you're
working yeah well if I did that then
everything we shot doesn't match and it
makes no sense it's just like doing coke
and just coming up like I don't know
it's just weird thoughts all the time
and but I mean a lot of times I don't
want to like name all these names of
people but I'm
working on one movie that never happened
and whatever was the number one movie
that from that weekend was exactly the
notes I would get for what we were
working on it didn't and I swear it was
around the time of private parts and
private parts was number one I go I
guarantee when I walk in the office is
gonna say can we get Howard Stern in
this movie and they did know it didn't
matter what it was if it was Starship
Troopers ago can we get giant bugs in
this movie suddenly wasn't the Halloween
movies is another movie that never
actually happened but and you just like
the little insanity the uncreated
executive that wants to be creative is
that is a classic story in Hollywood I
mean that's that's really like a villain
in a film about a movie about a guy
trying to make a movie yeah I mean I
thought we thought I will give credit
for things like I'm remember working
with Bob Weinstein and I always thought
like the first thing he would say was
spot-on
like they love movies they have a good
sense of movies and he would say
something you'd be like yeah then it
happens between the second and the third
act it's a bunch of [ __ ] that
doesn't work and you go yeah you're
right it is but like when he went to the
next level of the detail of what's wrong
with it it's kind of like someone going
like that jokes not funny here's how it
would be funny be nothing right the
first part of your sentence was all
heated I don't need you now to tell me
how to make it funny and that's what
happens I like when you I don't do them
anymore but back when I would be forced
to do test screenings with an audience
you could just sitting there you'll know
you know okay they're bored during this
part it's boring or they're not laughing
it's supposed to be funny I don't now
need that kid to get up and explain to
the studio how to save the picture
because you watched a movie once so that
the process is like half good and half
insanity do you get any people upset
that in some way you might be glorifying
violence maybe but I never hear about it
because I don't think that's true I mean
or if it is true it doesn't I don't
think it matters really because it's
fake it's not real right I mean it's
like I don't I don't think the rules of
real life apply to to art mmm I just
don't write because that's why art
exists just like you know
that ages and you just have to feel that
way because it's like okay well if we're
gonna run every movie through the PC
filter then in American History X Edward
Norton can't be racist sure you know how
we actually we don't have a movie or
running out you know Travis Bickle can't
kill anyone he just has to save Jodie
Foster because he's a nice person all
right you know yeah we're just they have
ruins everything I mean but the rules of
real life are different but for fiction
I mean they can't be rules right and how
else are you going to depict these
absolutely possible scenarios like if
we're saying that there isn't suicidal
maniacs in real life like well that's
nonsense so if you're allowed to make a
depiction of real life yeah of course
it's going to have to include racists
murderers Psychopaths and I just think
it's you know it's it's art and it can
go anywhere and it's always if it's
shocking that's probably good and it
won't be shocking next year like how
whatever you're showing your kids at one
point was shocking now they're like
seriously dead yeah we were talking
about jaws that yeah jaws today
apparently would be PG it was PG then
what's it can you believe that
no yeah was it it was oh my god it was
just shocking especially scare the [ __ ]
well that's because I bears took us to
see it which was awesome but I was
traumatized for sure yeah that was a
crazy movie I didn't want to have
anything to do with the water after that
movie yeah I still don't but the special
effects as well man when that shark
rises out of the water for the first
time he's thrown the Chum in the water
man come on down here jump some of this
[ __ ] was gonna need a bigger boat like
it's hard to believe those lines were
like once just lines in a script yeah I
know they're iconic yeah they're a part
of culture now it's amazing yeah do you
think that there is there a style of
film or a kind of movie that you want to
do that you haven't done yet that you're
thinking you'd like to get into I mean
there's two different projects I tried
to develop for a long time and they both
failed to get off the ground one was
this movie called the Broad Street
Bullies and it was about the 1974
Philadelphia Flyers and the movie is the
true story is so insane that you can't
believe it's
just the way that they decided you know
there are a fledgling team nobody cared
so they basically built a team of tough
guys you know which is kind of like slap
shots almost like won the Stanley Cup
twice based on just being so scared so
in so terrorizing other teams would be
scared to play them know be like oh you
got the Philly flu cuz major players be
like I have to sick to play when we get
to Philly
cuz then you go back and you watch the
fights that took place during those
those seasons they literally go into the
crowd and they're fighting with fans
they come off the ice they break up I
mean when the guys are fighting it's not
and it doesn't seem like good natured
like okay we're gonna go we're gonna go
it seems like gripping someone's hair
and punching them in the face till their
teeth are all gone type fighting cops
are breaking up the fights on the ice
cops cops with skates no pull uniformed
policemen come onto the ice and start
breaking things that but they're sliding
around with her yeah trying to YouTube
it's amazing I mean I just I research
this for years
and um and then they just you know and
Bobby Clark at that time was like the
most hated man and hockey I don't know
if you're a hockey fan at all but he's
just like another one those guys who was
he had I don't know I could go on
forever for a movie didn't make but but
I kept trying to make it go and go and
she could just never you could just
never and I wasn't went to Philadelphia
I was hanging out with the team and I
was in their archives and having access
to everything I love this is gonna
happen and just couldn't it wouldn't
move why I don't know I don't know I
don't know if the team and the team
owners want to glorify that time in the
in if there's an amazing documentary on
it that was on HBO maybe like five years
ago you got to watch it what's it do
minutes it might have been called Broad
Street Bullies because it was you know
the spectrum was on Broad Street mm-hmm
so that's how they good thing but it's
nuts and I was like you know the Dave
Schultz these weren't like a Nazi helmet
he was the tough guy on the team that
everybody pitch fried of and these guys
are like had really long hair and big
beards I mean it is not like hockey look
like a maniac and they'd get stuff like
you know you'd see them get stitches get
hit get stitched go back on the ice with
the stitches there's jerseys covered in
blood
and they don't even change their Jersey
they're playing covered in blood well
that's such a crazy something you'll
never do now well the sport still to
this day is such a throwback because
it's the only sport we are allowed to
fight in the middle of the sport imagine
if they had that with basketball hockey
players are the toughest [ __ ]
because I always loved hockey I want to
be a hockey player when I was a little
kid and that was one thing and for a
long time me my wife we had season
tickets for the Kings we'd go to every
single game for year after year after
year and we'd always hang out with the
team and they'd come to our house and
then party and we'd always be with them
in Vegas and they're like football
players on skates and they're all for
like these like guys I'm like Moose Jaw
Saskatchewan and like teeth out and they
get crazy in the bar and like mental and
they're just like who else is skating 90
miles now crashing into boards yeah that
are just to have no give but it's so
interesting that it's the one sport
where it's written in that you can fight
they fight I mean it's so funny it's so
crazy like that would make so many
sports so much more interesting but
nobody would ever do it yes it's
literally the tough-guy sport it is the
tough guys poor and the thing that
always drove me crazy like drove me
crazy like it involves me but they would
always advertise the LA Kings as like
it's like this family thing like oh come
on down and cheer for the Kings and be
like a girl in a hockey jersey on the
billboards around town like you should
just put up mug shot style portraits of
the players like smiling with their
teeth missing and it just says you think
you're [ __ ] tough right Kings because
yeah and it's not like the old days
where they're kind of like skillful
they're like this guy's like six foot
five and you put them on skates and
they're huge in the you know they
they're all jacked up and big like
football players except their own skates
Marcel for a lot of people putting up
but it's not a hard sell as MMA which is
weird
right because that's like the darling of
so many you go to the fights and Matt
Damon will be there and Leonardo
DiCaprio and everybody wants to be seen
there and Kanye's in the crowd and it's
one of those things where people have
decided like that's okay meanwhile
they're smashing their faces open with
elbows on the ground mental man heads
traffic
and they're pummeling each other it's
okay and he watches the they break it up
like I'm pretty sure that guy's already
got brain damage
you needed to stop that punching yo
seconds earlier well it's this Oh crazy
sport because it's become accepted like
like that's what I'm saying it's weird
like a fight in a basketball game is it
giant be okay oh my god it's like crazy
yeah if a guy you know like judo tossed
a guy and landed on his head somebody
did that recently in a hockey game was
awful like Robin black to the breakdown
of it where some guy got a guy in a
clinch and hit him with a hip toss and
slammed his head onto the concrete is
horrible it's weird what I mean I could
see why they they want I think they
probably like hockey being more
family-friendly because the arena's are
so nice you bring the guns and they
don't want a bunch of maniacs beating
the [ __ ] out of each other but they
could still fight they could still fight
but it is just watch this this is crazy
boom oh that's bad that's horrible
that's an [ __ ] move because like
that's not even fighting like and Plus
that guy ended with both of their
weights guys on his head he's out called
I mean that's like serious serious
[ __ ] brain yeah I remember one time
one particular incident at Kings game
where the guy was out and it went on
forever and the vibe was so heavy in the
arena cuz boy is he dead because you
know we don't when someone hits and they
just stop stiffen up freaks you out you
pull up some Broad Street Bullies
fighting from 1974 pull up some of that
yeah I've seen Dave Schultz oh that's
this thing yeah this is the documentary
it's amazing oh look at the way they
look back there yeah everything it's
like back in the day it's just such a
weird thing to see people from that era
yeah they don't this is like early days
before they became insane oh so it built
up because what happened was when they
were starting as a team they got really
manhandled one time by a certain team
and they're like this is never gonna
happen again and they rebuilt the team
would basically like thug type guys I'm
always amazing anybody could punch while
they're on skates and that's I can't
skate how the [ __ ] do you maintain your
I don't know these guys are amazing
athletes I one time I went I went down
and got
skate at practice with the LA Kings with
that guys were injured and then that
rink seems small when those big guys are
all get on their ice it seems like wow
there's no room up here but it's also
they collide into each other against the
wall which the amount of shock on your
body
I know it's amazing that I mean they
just go and go and go then the angels
reignite some interest with this
conversation because I think that would
be it well he's pulling his [ __ ] hair
yeah oh it wasn't what it was it's
amazing so have you tried again recently
or I I try li think that this is like
they just don't want to be connected to
this story well there's this guy ed
Snyder who was the guy who started a
whole team and that's four and I met
with I thought he was the reason it
wasn't gonna happen and then he passed
away because I mean he's pretty old and
then we started talking to the newer
people and it just I don't know how many
years my my life I got addicted you know
right you don't know and someone said to
me one time well you got further than
anyone else ever did I'm like how many
times are they try to make this movie I
need to warn me about that five years
ago is there any other kind of movie
that you're interested in other than
something like that well yeah there was
this other one that I worked on for a
long time that never went either I had
bought the rights to this book called
raised eyebrows which was a light that
about the last few years of Groucho
Marx's life this guy Steve stole you
wrote it and he was a 19 year old
college kid who started this petition
drive do you like the Marx Brothers
yeah and because animal crackers had
been lost that was the loss film and it
you see I think was at UCLA sorry Steve
I can't remember your college he started
this petition drive to get animal
crackers released from the vaults and
released because they hadn't been seen
since like the 40s or something and he
did this was in this this was in the
early 70s and through that he became
Groucho's assistant but Groucho's final
years are really dark because he kept
having strokes and he was ill any of
this woman Erin Fleming whose post
abused they kind of played it like it
was his girlfriend but she was with a
caretaker and it was turns into Sunset
Boulevard inside his house you know and
Steve eventually is put in charge of
Groucho
because that it's a really darn
set-builder how so because she guard she
was being abused and drugged by this
woman she isolated from his family and
it's like happening in his Beverly Hills
home and it's just dark it was dark
towards the end for Groucho
yeah and cuz the guy wrote it Steve
who's you know still alive and we're
friends I was just like it was one of
the books you're reading like five
seconds and I just happened to find it
by accident I like this is an amazing
movie but again years and years going on
and trying to get at me and just can't
get it going Groucho was such a
controversial character and one of the
greatest lines ever and you bet your
life he's talking to this guy and he's
asked a guy like you married yes how
many kids you got this cigar like yeah
he's got a gang kids it he goes Jesus he
goes he goes oh I love my wife because I
love my cigar too but I take it out of
my mouth every now and then yeah that is
that was a hugely controversial line
yeah he's amazing and he was like and he
was very high brows yeah there it is he
was very outspoken he was like on
Nixon's [ __ ] list and stuff and my give
me an inside Groucho's house yeah it's
really fast if you get that book you'll
read in like two seconds that's it's
always sad when some iconic old figure
like is being taken care of as he's
older and you know he's getting [ __ ]
over and someone's waiting for him to
dies they can get the money yeah and she
kept kind of doing saying like we're
gonna make you come back Groucho and
we're gonna do us TV specials enemy you
know like you and Frank Sinatra and
Groucho's like you know had on his like
third stroke and like can't really talk
or you know oh it was just like and a
couple of the final appearances of him
are pretty rough because he was pretty
sharp and good even when he was old
early for watching my dick cavett or
something but then it got bad and then
how did this lady get into his life she
was uh I mean I think she was a
secretary at first and just kind of
weasel their way in oh I can't remember
exactly I should I should be able
remember I read the book so many times
there's so many stories like that of
like oh I think there was a Stan Lee
story like that and his last few days
that happens a lot yeah people were
trying to get his money I remember
remember that Martha Raye yes that was
like the end with her like who's like oh
and her boyfriend she's like this and a
wee
oh that's right [ __ ] oh yeah that is sad
[ __ ] and their kids are done with them
and so someone else is taking care of
her they're so old their kids have all
died of old age you know and this is
like you know so you wanted to do that
film yeah what happened that it just be
just couldn't get it going and we
thought we'd every time it seemed like
we were on the move it just would stall
and then I had a falling-out with the
producers and I was like hey you know
five years spent with this I'm out oh my
god the drain at time yeah that's the
thing like for every movie I've ever
gotten made there's probably five others
that I tried to get made they couldn't
get made something it's a real time suck
yeah that's that's a [ __ ] huge drag
man now when you when you do get a film
made is it generally that you come to
the studio and you have this idea and
you bring it to them and yeah it's
usually like well the Halloween movies
were different because I remember I did
I had no thought I wasn't thinking about
Halloween I was think about anything
like that and I got the thing like oh
you know the weinstein company wants you
to go have a meeting with them Bob
Weinstein he's in LA yada yada yada so I
go in to meet him and he's just like
Halloween what do you think it's great
[ __ ] movie I mean I didn't know what
he was getting it he's like we own the
rights and we want to do something with
it we don't know what to do because they
didn't know if they want to make another
sequel or just call it Halloween but not
have Michael Myers a nothing like there
was no preconceived idea and it was my
idea to basically try to reboot it start
over with new people playing all the
same roles and do that and that was came
out 2007 so as per 2006 when I did that
who was involved in the more recent one
Lionsgate is the company that did the
three from hell because I had done after
Universal booted me with house 1000
corpses it was eventually acquired by
Lionsgate and Lionsgate made the sequel
Devil's Rejects and then which was
already 15 years ago and a couple years
ago I got a real bug to make another one
I just went into Lionsgate when it was
the same executive still there I was
like what do you think about doing this
and they're like they were saying you
know what that was the last really fun
time we had making
movies let's do it that's gonna feel
good yeah it was great I was like wow
that's sad but okay now do you have
long-term plans like in terms of like
what you want to accomplish as a guy who
makes movies well yes and no I mean I
don't have a I'm not trying to gear up
towards making bigger films because I
know I wouldn't work in that system
because it's just now I don't want to
make things by committee I was like this
is the [ __ ] up crazy thing I want to
do and I don't want to water because I
know so many people that'll be like like
our friend Tom Papa I remember him
telling me about his TV show come to
Papa that it was like this certain idea
he said by the time the TV people
watered it down and changed it he gets
on the airs like well so far removed
from the original idea yeah that I don't
you know I don't want to do that and you
know and so I would rather my goal is
just get it made
whatever it takes I'm worried about
don't try to be blockbuster guy I don't
care I mean I've you know had the
Halloween movies we're on four thousand
screens it was like the number one movie
made oh but it didn't make me any
happier it's just about making the thing
where I can look anyway I love it I'm
done cuz you know that's at this stage
that's what I want to do yeah that the
genre is still so attractive but there's
just not a lot of those examples other
than like well your films are probably
the most prominent currently well I mean
if everything's meant I mean horror
movies are big business but if they look
at it that way then they start making
them overly palatable to a wide audience
this types of horror movies though you
know there's like supernatural horror
movies there's monster movies but then
there's like homicidal maniac movies
this is so much [ __ ] redneck homicides
that I mean who's that's my job you know
it's like The Hills Have Eyes yeah right
and you there you go right
I mean it's like that kind of psychopath
Chainsaw Massacre type [ __ ] I love white
trash
type stuff well the carnie because
that's just yeah I was that typical kid
who worshiped Evel Knievel
I mean that he that would be a that
would be a movie the happy a [ __ ]
movie man I worked with his son I work
with Robbie Bobby Knievel and during the
Fear Factor days alright yeah he did
something on fear factor yeah it was
cool he's a nice guy but you know I was
like damn dude your dad was a [ __ ]
psycho yes [ __ ] that guy subjected his
body to it's crazy and when you watched
that [ __ ] and you watched the
Philadelphia Flyers that this [ __ ]
mental it was not just a little kid
watching Evel Knievel and listening to
Alice Cooper and watching hockey fights
and that determines who you become
Knievel was just I mean there's a I
think it was a Rolling Stone piece of
his body where they showed all of his
x-rays and all of the Railly bone breaks
and steel rods that were various bones
that were screwed together and like [ __ ]
man what kind of pain was this guy in I
don't know I mean did you see that
there's a fairly new documentary I think
it's called beam Knievel I think it's
amazing well it's maybe a couple years
old actually but um yeah just any one of
those crashes I think this is a famous
one in London and he jumps over the
double-decker buses and you can see him
land and the bike looks like it's made
out of rubber and he looks like he's
made everything like it looks like every
bone in his body just broke and that's
you know it's gonna do it again and do
it again oh god I mean that was his
thing imagine that being your thing your
thing is you fly through the air on
something that's supposed to stay on the
ground a full-size Harley that's not
made for jumping or doing anything at
all and landing for that manner doesn't
have any particularly like like bouncy
shocks or anything it's just hitting
like cool Katan and just oh my god yeah
it's it's a weird thing to be that guy
because there was I mean there was some
people in the past that had done some
pretty interesting [ __ ] and risked their
lives but he was doing it consistently
with an engine that was a thing about
him it's like and he was like one of the
most famous people in America yeah with
the like an American flag suit yeah is
like the Fonz and Knievel I know
area being Knievel you gotta see that a
fancy wow that's amazing Wow and there's
stuff in there that kind of blew my mind
cuz we all remember the Snake River
Canyon yes but they were showing how out
of control it was with the people that
showed up and were so drunk and the
crowds were fighting and crazy just on
there oh it's it mental like just what's
going on around the the event that's one
of those things you can't really do
today the same way like if someone jumps
over things today it's like so many
people are jumping like you're not gonna
get famous that way because they think
about the just the bananas [ __ ] those
BMX guys do with their pho yeah three
times in the air it's commonplace ya
know watch an Evel Knievel's like
watching the original King Kong with
your kids it's like oh that was a big
deal once he jumped seven buses whatever
I did it on my bike yeah that would be a
great film I don't know what you have to
do now catch bullets with your bare
hands bullet man you know well now
there's people doing parkour and
climbing buildings with no ropes that's
like you ever watched that kid Alex
Honnold
do you know you know he's the free solo
the free solo guy yeah oh I still
haven't seen that yet better he's so
nice and so normal when you talk to him
I've had him on the podcast a couple of
times and I'm like how are you the guy
that's wanting to climb the faces [ __ ]
cliffs and some of them weird they're
they're not straight up and down they're
holding on by a finger let's get like
hands wedged in these crackling look at
that picture yeah that's my that doesn't
make you [ __ ] your pants and he's
getting older and he's starting to get
injured now too
and you know he's for the first time in
his life he's had you know like you know
for a long time he had no injuries no
problems and he's I always been doing
this a long time now his body's not
holding up the way it used to when do
you retire like when do you retire
little Knievel and you know it's time
the finger slips yeah
when you retire I mean that's what all
of the people that have done it before
him think they think look this is gonna
end badly yeah you know it's it's crazy
to be known as the guy who's doing
something that scares the [ __ ] out of
everybody yeah you're the guy that
everybody's watching to eventually fall
look at that like a look at the angle
that doesn't even seem possible
well he's incredibly strong his hands
like he's a slender thin guy but he has
gorilla hands yeah the fat ass fingers
and he just can shove them into these
cracks and hang on in place he was
telling me a story about how he was free
solo climbing this one mountain when he
realized you know like [ __ ] 300 feet
up that he forgot his powder so he's got
no chalk so he's you know things are
getting slippery he's climbing and he
finds these guys that are connected to
ropes halfway up and he says hey I don't
have any powder can I borrow your chalk
that's the guy that's trot bag he makes
it all the way to top and leaves the
chalk bag at the top for the guy it's
like one of those guys like ropes he's
going by no rope so much [ __ ] chalk
like you know like if you ever lifted
weights like with that bar gets slippery
it sucks like you need chalk yeah to
grip things right so you can you could
really get a hold of stuff but that's
just weights you could put the weights
on the worst fall is gonna be three feet
to the floor
[ __ ] I can't I can't even watch his
tongue I'm like my hands are sweating
right now anything about it
I haven't watched that but I got two and
everyone's always talking about no it's
an amazing documentary but he said just
a fascinating guy because it doesn't
make sense he's not like some steve-o
type guy there's a maniac and just like
always trying to freak people out and do
the next thing no I'm gonna rock it on a
sharpened car yeah crashed into a brick
wall exactly exactly
like when steve-o comes up with ideas
like he'll tell him to me I'm like don't
do that don't do that man like stop
doing that oh but I get it that's who he
is he's an he's a legitimate bona fide
maniac yeah Alex Honnold guys so calm
and peaceful you know he said like he's
like well you know I'm pretty Mel
you know it's like when the whole thing
is pretty mellow it's like when things
go wrong that's when it's not mellow oh
God
yeah yeah I know how everything is yeah
so do you see things like that like
current events stuff or like personally
came and think hmmm was that movie is
there a movie in there like sometimes I
see things I'm trying the last time I
thought that and I'm always late like
you'll go oh I just saw that hello it's
already in production
I've never ahead of the curve enough to
be uh that's a bummer you know yeah but
no there's all kinds of things like that
that I would love to do but it's like it
just I don't know it's time sometimes I
just I've tried like I said I told you
two projects that took so much of my
life I mean I sat there and watched the
because the whole flyers movie ended
with them winning the cup the first time
and I watched that series I got all the
games on with all the original
commercials which was incredible
Herschel's a Salvador Dali selling house
paint like weird [ __ ] and I had them I
had the whole series I memorized I could
have called the commentary on I watched
thousands of hours of watching this
hockey because I was like if I'm gonna
make this movie I'm gonna be the number
one Phillies expert on everything I
don't want anyone to say anything I'm
like oh gee oh no now I can't remember
anything and then it was all for nothing
oh but that's so that's the way things
are anyway though but so you invested
too much yeah but you kind of had to
because it's like I figured with a topic
like that they have such the fans are
right I mean they're like that they're
like gods in Philadelphia I mean the
best thing about this just think of this
as a movie ok just these one scene when
they introduced the team in Philly I
think was 1967 they had a parade to
introduce them because of hockey was
coming to town they said they had a
parade with the players and it was like
maybe no one there to watch the parade
and even then one of the guys goes all I
remember is a guy leaning on the
lamppost giving me the finger as the
parade went by and then when they won
the Stanley Cup they had a parade two
million people showed up in the streets
of Philadelphia in the foot
that if you can find it while you're ho
there the entire you know like a hundred
thousand people show for the Lakers
hemos crazy two million people is for
Woodstock's
in the streets in the streets of
Philadelphia to watch a team drive by
and like in the back of like you know
convertibles and they're all good they
all look like porn stars cuz our fur
coats big mustaches and big afros they
were amazing it's like just the and that
was such a short period of time that was
maybe like seven years from go [ __ ]
yourself to like you guys are
Philadelphia wow it was all during that
time period of like you know when they
made Rocky so Philadelphia like the
[ __ ] of them America you know and
then every sports team was bad and the
the the the real-life story just reads
like fiction I mean holy [ __ ] and that
was the entire parade road people are
hanging out of buildings it was just it
was the that's when they won the game
was just incredible well showing up in
Boston believe it or not I wasn't a
hockey fan I didn't I was just into
martial arts and I didn't even like
sports I just was I found out about
martial arts really the school that I
want up going to because I was coming
home from a Red Sox game I was in a
baseball at the time and I went up to
this gym and this martial arts Taekwondo
school and I happened to be going there
right when this guy his name was John
Lee was practicing and he was national
heavy and light heavyweight champion at
the time and this is incredible and I
got to see him hit this bag and I
remember thinking I can't believe
someone can do that yeah like he hit it
so hard he was kicking this bag I was
like [ __ ] I want to learn how to do that
but what year was that this was 19 I was
15 14 15 so 81 82 somewhere around there
ok and when I was 19 years old saw but
really wasn't paying attention at all to
support those balls into martial arts
but I was working at the Boston Athletic
Club and Bobby Orr who was long retired
used to come there to work out all right
and he had had so many knee surgeries I
was terrible that I used to have to help
him I mean everybody was like holy [ __ ]
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba I didn't I kind of knew
he was Bobby Orr but it did it wasn't
like I was meeting Bruce Lee or
something I was meeting Bruce Lee I
probably fainted but it was yeah it was
this hockey player guy and I used to
have to help him to get on the verse or
climber you know diverse climbers know
there's one of them out there in the gym
you you climb on it it's an amazing
cardio machine but you put your feet in
these things it was in rocky like
petrology Drago was working on it but
Bobby wanted to get on this thing so I
used to have to help him
because he couldn't bend his knees his
knees like the range of motion like
here's here's a leg here's a normal
range of motion right his knees would go
like this they wouldn't lock all the way
out they would Bend slightly and they
would move from this bent slightly to
this that's all he had that's crazy he
had a little bit of Bend in his knees
that's it yeah he would play racquetball
and he would just fall over so he like
you play rattle but the ball was over
here fall over it was like he was on
these legs that weren't legs it was like
he was on sticks they just didn't work
you know and I remember seeing the
scarves up and down the sides of his
yeah I've ever seen those as a kid like
that you'd see pictures I have followed
the Bruins how I was always into Bobby
Orr and yeah he probably always was back
on the ice too soon another injury yep
stitch him up rip oh yeah no I didn't
know how to fix things back then either
and he's so incredibly or was like at
that time like if young Brad Pitt was
the greatest hockey player of all time I
mean he didn't even seem real right you
know I think the Golden Boy and I'm
keeping making you Paula party clothes
but like you see some clips and it's
like the way he's skating compared to
everyone else it's like did everyone
else just learn that day like he's just
skating around I'm like they don't even
exist it's just as like and as a kid
you're like this is the greatest person
alive well that's next thing people
Knievel also why he blew his knees out
right because he was just it was taking
these crazy risks and moving so probably
yeah I mean he was just people are
probably trying to take him out left and
right - yeah I mean he and the well the
thing with him - he was a defenseman
not a forward so he
play like a Ford but he would be a
defenseman so he's supposed to be the
tough guy defending the goalie yet he's
like a leading scorer so he was sort of
too good for everything so he's like
yeah so he's taking all the hits and
scoring all the goals he was such a nice
guy I remember thinking that too when I
was a kid I always used to be
intimidated by people who are really
nice guys
how's he so nice cuz I was kind of a
prick drive me crazy like that he was so
now I felt inferior I was like god I
wish I was that nice you know yeah every
I get I know you mean we know it was a
mean kid because I was fighting and I
was like the fight is to be mean yeah
you want to get good at fighting you
gotta be [ __ ] means yeah by then I'm
five years into fighting and all I want
to do and so I'm around this guy I feel
like he's so he's so nice and he's like
the greatest hockey player of all time
[ __ ] yeah it's funny I remember in high
school the kids that would always be in
the fights and kick everyone's ass feel
like you can't compete with that
he's just born crazy he likes to fight
you punch him in the face it'll probably
make him happy after he smashes your
head into the sink and you know kills
you it's just like it's a different way
people well I never got into I wasn't
really a street fight person at all I
was scared of it that's how I got into
martial arts because I was scared of
fighting but the the the difference
between people that were like a Bobby
Orr or a regular player always
fascinated me I was like how is one guy
Michael Jordan yeah all right how was
one guy how's one guy you know Reggie
Jackson what is he doing different how
does this guy rise above everybody else
they're just special because I would
read about him and be like you know they
knew he was good when he was a kid the
bet come watch this eight year old I was
skating people like he was I think I
forget I'm I don't want to I'm not a
Bobby Orr expert I can't remember things
but I remember the like you know being
scouted at 14 like he was an adult he
was so good but that's what you have to
be I guess you know I mean they're just
some kid I mean we all remember kids
from high school that's like why are you
right you're like a professional athlete
and we're like stupid kids yeah
you know right like why are you shredded
just like dopey kids like what's going
on what kind of musicians to write
remember when Prince first came out
wasn't he like 19 when he came out with
I want to be your lover yeah some people
are just special yeah they're just
Mozart but in fighting or it's so
humbling yeah well that's what goes back
to the thing we said like an hour ago
fooled them again guys like those guys
are so special well there's always gonna
be people like that right they just put
it all into perspective for you and make
you realize like wow just okay I'm a
regular person it's fun watching people
like that but yeah but then there's
people like that sometimes that they
just self-destruct because they don't
care that they're good right you know
and I remember people like that too and
like they do nothing with it that's true
too you know which is weird
yeah there's sometimes people can be too
talented where things come too easy it
doesn't mean anything yeah there's a
thing like you know you were talking
about earlier about being bullied like
maybe if we get rid of bullying we're
gonna get rid of a certain amount of
success to mean something I don't want
anybody to hurt their feelings but I
understand that there's something that
comes out of that right well there's
something that comes out of it being
really hard for you to do that when ya
figure I gotta do it you've developed
this indomitable spirit because you've
managed to make your way through the
hardest levels of the game to get to the
top it's not like you were just faster
than everybody yeah have bigger muscles
and your [ __ ] heads thicker or
something yeah I mean yeah you can't be
like Pro bullying because that's weird
but I but there is something to it
because like real life just bullies you
anyway there's something to adversity
like you have to be able to like like
where people like whenever someone says
like what's your advice for like you
know doing this like being in show
business or something I go if being told
by complete strangers that you suck all
day long does not bother you in any way
you know then maybe it's the business
for you yeah maybe it's not because I
think it bothers everybody who wants to
join there's a difference between
bothering like that's a drag or like
right this is always funny whenever
someone comes to me in a silly
he wrote this short story be brutally
honest I mean brutally honest that
person's like secretly saying please say
something nice above course yeah come
watch my show be brutal is brutally
honest you're hideous to look at you the
least talented person I ever seen in my
life that's such a request like I've had
people ask me to read their scripts I'm
like hey bro you're asking me for an
hour and a half of my time
yeah I don't even know you do yeah a
valuable an hour and a half is I have
children and three jobs and a lot of
hobbies I don't have an hour and a half
to watch move I don't want to read a
script when my agent sends it over I
don't want to read yours I mean they
think that I'm suck if I could just get
this Rob Zombie if I could just get this
Rob Zombie he can make it then it all
work out it's so funny the people that
always make it never talk about
themselves know people that can't
telling you about their great idea it's
very rarely an idea it's very rare that
ideas actually great yeah yeah I think
there's certain qualities that someone
has to have to make something that's
truly exceptional and very rarely do
they want to tell you that it's truly
exceptional yeah I mean it's weird like
maybe it's the insecurity thing that you
don't want to tell anybody what you do
because you don't ever think it's good
enough as opposed to people that are not
good enough and they always want to tell
you about themselves right yeah that's a
problem the wrong people are talking
about themself well it's like it's human
psychology but I think the thing about
like I was saying about Richard Jeni
would say that looking at shitty comics
is what inspires people to do comedy
there we learn from all of the
psychological disasters all the people
that think like all the guys that think
they're better looking than they are
like then they walk up to a girl what
the [ __ ] you talkin out of here like
it's something there's something to be
learned from that like you know I had a
friend growing up that would swing at
every pitch this guy would go up to
every girl and he didn't he wasn't a
particularly good-looking guy he wasn't
smart
he wasn't funny he but he was bold yes
and you know he and I would learn from
him like girls would be angry at him
like angry that he had the balls to ask
them out and then they probably would go
right because they were really you got
to very few his strategy just didn't
work it didn't work at all not out
find girls with something wrong with
them like there's something wrong
whether they have a screw loose I that
story was going to be his boldness paid
off no he says disaster I've lost touch
with him 15 20 years ago he's out of his
[ __ ] mind but I remember when we were
kids Jesus Christ cuz I the one of the
things about getting the show business
that helped me is I was always super
insecure to talk to girls but then when
you wouldn't you would I would do
stand-up you would do work at clubs and
you'd be the guy on stage making people
laugh like they wanted to talk to you
like you actually want to talk to me
this is crazy you know I couldn't
believe that that's weird that guy would
just [ __ ] anybody like he would every
flight attendant there's but you can
learn from people that [ __ ] everything
up yeah you can't you learn from
everything though but I have this theory
that nobody can learn from other
people's mistakes really it's written
it's the maybe it's just the way you
think and I think but it's the rare
person who learns from other people's
mistakes
yeah it's rare but it's possible because
I always think like heroine right didn't
Lou Reed finish that one for everybody
we're still gonna give it a go but it's
different when you do heroin or just
anything I mean I never know anyone that
learns from anyone's mistake because you
can even if you're in the business and
you go look here's my piece but don't
spend that money on that because that's
the only gonna see put it away do this
cuz that's an advance that's not coming
every month right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then you know two months later
they're broke right you know it's like I
have stuff I don't give people advice
because they don't want to hear it I
don't care be the people who want to
really want advice and they're gonna use
it it's like one out of a hundred but
they do exist yeah but it's rare yeah
and those are the people that are smart
knowing aha
yeah I try to learn as much as I can
from other people's mistakes but if they
don't feel as bad as they feel to those
people mister - yeah the [ __ ] hurt
man like bombing like bombing on stage
is
suck in a thousand dicks in front of
Maya it hurts so bad that you learn like
okay I am gonna figure this out I'm
never having that happen again I gotta I
gotta get better that must be so bad
relate to it because you know I've done
a different sort of bombing in front of
people on stage but you can't really
learn from other people bombing I think
you kind of that's one of those things
you kind of got to do yourself how long
does it take because I'm always
fascinated by how long do you feel it
takes I mean this is not really a
question I guess you can answer but till
you find your voice and you go okay this
is me I'm this guy I'm not I'm not ready
liar I'm not Jerry Seinfeld it depends I
mean some people maybe never find it I
guess but a lot of people never find it
there's impossible comics whereas like
you you see them and you go oh my god
this poor bastard was trying to do
something that he's never gonna be able
to do there's people that just they're
never going to be able to do it for
whatever reason whatever whatever
psychological ingredients that they have
it's not enough to make chocolate cake
like you don't have any eggs you know I
mean flour yeah you're [ __ ] yeah I I
know yeah
but then there's other people that their
ego protects them where they they
believe that they did well when they
didn't do well they're delusional and
that's the worst thing because they
they're trying to protect themselves
from the bad feeling but they understand
the bad feeling is your friend because
that's it sucks hard but yeah that's the
[ __ ] medicine that you take that
medicine you gotta go okay what did I do
wrong this is what I did wrong I cannot
do that again you got to put more time
and focus and effort it's really
dependent it's almost entirely on how
much you do that objectively and your
focus like how you can look at it some
people just don't ever wanna no matter
what they're doing whether they're
painting or write making comic books
they don't want to ever look at it the
way other people look at it they want to
think that everything they do is amazing
you know mm-hmm like a that's true my
kids will show me something and
sometimes it'll be funny like you know
my daughter will make something on an
iPad sometimes it'll be funny and
sometimes it's like look they think it's
great why cuz they're she's [ __ ] nine
okay but
you're 28 and you think everything you
do is amazing it's like okay but do you
think that's worse now because of things
like Instagram oh for sure your
everybody puts up anything and you want
to go you look like an idiot but your
friends like you are so or something you
know like everyone's can they can feed
their delusions that's that's certainly
but you also could take the sting of
criticism and you get it from way more
people like if you someone you put
something up on Instagram you think it's
funny and then that people come at you
hard like whoa like you might you know
if you're a comic and you've been doing
stand-up for five years you're never
gonna work in front of none normal
circumstances you're never gonna work in
front of 5,000 people but you might get
5,000 people saying you suck if you put
something up on Instagram that's true
you know yeah I mean you can tell and I
mean I'm sure you can tell when
somebody's funny almost instantly you
can tell but some people surprise you
like some people in the beginning like
wow this guy's got it rough but then one
day they it just clicks and they just
keep working at it and but it's a matter
of whether or not they're willing to put
the building blocks in the right place
and whether or not they're going to
admit that the structure that they have
currently is not viable right and some
people aren't
but some people are it's like it doesn't
and also well it's it's just like movies
right which like everybody's got a
different style you know your films are
your kind of films whereas like there's
other people that are doing like these
really simple sweet you know chick
flicks and that's for them that's what
they like and there's people that find
that and they think it's amazing it's so
good it's like you've got to find
whatever the [ __ ] it is that you do that
you would like to see yeah because
that's hot that's the only way you can
judge it yeah I mean I do what I do
because that's what I like so what I'm
doing I go okay but if I was trying to
do something else that I'd what didn't
get imma go what do I judge against like
what you're telling me is good then I'm
lost
well you'd be like the executive asking
you get Howard Stern in the movie like I
don't know why they want him in a movie
they just know he's famous movie just
get him
and that's what happened when when I was
doing the Halloween movies a lot because
they'd weigh in so often that it can
start messing with you because you don't
know which end is up because you just
want to go Jesus Christ can I just
[ __ ] focus for five seconds before
you send her another 18 pages of weird
notes [ __ ] with it and you really
don't know which end is up anymore there
for a film and I've been there on TV
shows it's a drag it's very confusing
because you don't know anymore because
you're so spun out from too much
information because most of find most of
the time and that's why I'll add offend
likes and like a filmmaker like Ed Wood
and why people still talk about plan 9
from outer space because yes technically
it's inept ended but there's something
so specific about this guy's bizarro
vision that you're still talking about
it and that something like Tim Burton
makes a movie about it there's a million
far superior made films from back then
that nobody gives a [ __ ] about it's just
like there's something about keeping
that weird bizarro vision alive and not
having the committee ruin it yeah if
enough people know that it's going to be
an Ed Wood movie they're gonna go see it
there's enough people that find out
about the like yeah that's weird [ __ ]
yeah you'll see it's weird how did he
make a movie more entertaining in six
days with like $300 and you made with
two hundred million dollars well
especially in the teeth after the test
the taste of time because if you look
back at it now I mean people will gather
round and watch it especially after the
giant Depp movie yeah because when
Johnny Depp was such a weird rate in
that so [ __ ] strange that's like the
phrase I think Edie would and like Young
Frankenstein at two times were like
that's like the perfect combo they're
just such perfect films Ed Wood is so
weird that the Johnny Depp version of my
kind of character are you right now
yeah I remember right when it came out
of nose right it was right when Martin
Landau got nominated for an Oscar I ran
into him at a newsstand and I couldn't I
never go up to people because I don't
bother anybody but I couldn't resist and
it was like one of those cases where he
was so nice that of like
you know which was great but he was
great in that and he seems so shocked
there like some young weird dude was
like so excited to see meet Martin
Landau because you know he's pretty old
and yeah that's cool what a movie like
that sort of reignites people's
appreciation for someone tonight always
been great yeah I mean cuz I was like a
space 1999 dork and stuff back of the
day is there ever a guy that you like
you you are such a big fan of as an
actor that you would kind of try to like
make a movie around them probably I mean
on the sad part is so many of the people
that I love are gone mmm you know like
I've tried to put a lot of people I
really love in all my movies a lot of
like just weird character actors from
the 70s that you'd see in like Clint
Eastwood movies and stuff but like
Jeffrey Lewis you know who's in like you
know sidekick in every which way but
loose and was in high place Juliette
Lewis is dead Jeffrey Lewis oh yeah and
he was like the greatest I worked with
him twice and he would have huge a Joey
the funniest story once he goes this is
what I learned from them I can't imitate
Marc but it was what I learned from
working with Clint
whenever I was in a scene with Clint I'd
make sure I put my hand on his shoulder
that way I knew he couldn't cut me out
of the scene but he was he was an
amazing guy I remember when I did this
animated movie with Tom papa called the
haunted world of Hell superb Easter and
Jeffrey Lewis's and he had just come
from boxing at that point he was in his
70s but he was like little but he was
like he had that Eastwood body where
he's still like ripped you know Clint
Eastwood you don't think him is like but
then he has that Charles Bronson body
back then were boxing in the 70s yeah he
came back and he was like don't be
fooled I can still kick your ass oh yeah
hilarious guy you know a movie that I
[ __ ] loved that it hardly gets talked
about anymore it's bad lieutenant yeah
Harvey Keitel you don't hear from Harvey
Keitel anymore for whatever reason well
I fit is he is he in the new thing that
Irishman the Scorsese I don't know he
sounds like he should be that [ __ ] guy
has depth he's amazing when he gets
there's scenes in movies when he gets
angry are you like Jesus Christ like
this this is real like he's he's hit
this weird place where he might murder
the person he's in the
I know he's I always wonder what this
I've heard different weird stories of
why because he was in Eyes Wide Shut
right and Kubrick filming for a long
time and then replaced him with Sydney
[ __ ] why I don't know
but I would always hear these different
weird like that weird that there was
weird [ __ ] that he did and I don't know
it's true so I don't repeat it but I was
wonder because he's so great
yeah but to shoot for six weeks or two
months and then be replaced it was a
weird thing well he is his scenes
there's something about him like like
pulp fiction he's so authentic like you
believe he's the cleaner you know he's
so great as like sport in like you know
taxi driver yes I think that might be
the first thing I saw him in so I was he
just seems so authentically sleazy I
used to have a bad lieutenant poster I
thought [ __ ] happened to it but
somewhere along my travels moving from
place to place I lost it but I remember
he's amazing that [ __ ] movie was so
crazy cuz it was like a bad cop he's a
movie but probably fairly realistic
probably until did you ever see the
documentary the 7/5 no it's a great
documentary about corrupt cops in New
York oh really
yeah and Michael Dowd who was one of the
guys who was one of those corrupt cops
one up going to jail and now he's out
and you know I had him on the podcast we
talked about and the pot it's [ __ ]
all of it is true
all of its documented in all of its
insane what year was that all happening
was that like was the 70s right what
year was I always assumed corruption
happened in the 70s it seemed like he
was showing up at the precinct with a
[ __ ] Corvette were knocking over 80s
and 90s
Oh was Wow Serpico time period yeah but
he's out now man and it's um it's just
one of those stories that's so [ __ ]
crazy just you know knocking the drug
hits out on him and they were putting
hits on other people it's like it's like
poof it's it's just maniacal who's that
in New York yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
like the West he but he talks about like
first
on the job being exposed to corruption
like they threw some guy out of a
[ __ ] balcony you know like like this
guy jumped right I think I forget what
the exact center was but some ridiculous
[ __ ] like that where they were he was
aiming is like it was corrupt long
before he got there yeah he just sort of
stepped into the the mess of it you know
it's like what you're talking about like
your early days in New York City like
seeing that guy get beat to death by a
cop like that was kind of how police had
total autonomy they mean they they had
so much power and authority back then
yeah it was crazy I remember another
incident this is right before I left
that I think I start talking about in
finish it was like they had Tompkins
Square Park and they were trying to
that's when it was that area was getting
gentrified that was the big word and
there was like kind of a riot there was
all the people protesting the
gentrification of the Lower East Side
this was probably like I don't know
maybe early 90s late 80s and the cops
showed up on horseback and I was I wish
I had just walked out to go to the deli
I didn't even know this was happening I
just walked right into the middle of
like what's going on here and then the
cops just started racing through the
crowd and I just started running and I
saw a friend of mine he he died um he
was a singer this punk rock band Reagan
youth and I saw this cop just jump on
him and start pounding on him so bad he
had really long dreadlocks the next time
I saw him his head was shaved and was
all stitched up because he just had so
much damage to his head he'd been like a
coma or something and then it was a big
scandal you could probably find us use
it because the cops all put black tape
on their badge numbers so that no one
could tell who was who while they did
all this [ __ ] and it was like on the
front cover the New York Post a picture
of like a I think the post the badge
with the black tape that [ __ ] was wild
deck back then see if we can find well
then the Chicago elections and the riots
during the 1960's yeah was like a
turning point in Hunter s Thompson's
life because he was there and he watched
these cops just beat the [ __ ] out of
people and he said that he saw far worse
beatings by the Chicago
the ever saw for the Hells Angels
because you know his first book yeah the
Hells Angels look so he was around those
guys for a year watching them get into
biker brawls and [ __ ] he's like this
[ __ ] paled it pales I mean it's yes
why but uh it's crazy too but sometimes
I being a cop must be a crazy job
horrific because I can't imagine
I mean I'm doesn't justify stuff we're
talking about but I can't imagine how
you couldn't go crazy in that job right
you see every day and what you most of
them I think of PTSD and you know they
don't it does it's not addressed most
people have disdain for them almost
everybody they meets a liar yes you mean
a guy oh I didn't know how fast I was
going oh this is my house I just can't
find my keys like everyone's lying to
you and you're the enemy you are a
professional enemy and you were an enemy
outfit yeah for all these criminals
enemy it's a terrible way to live yeah I
need them badly right it's in its I
don't know can't win on that job I don't
think no no you can't and it's and
people don't you don't get paid enough
people don't respect you they don't
appreciate you you know I want you
around no they want you around yeah and
then you're not there fast enough
exactly yeah yeah it's uh I mean and cop
movies that's what's crazy is like cop
movies people love people love cop
movies and the cops are the good guys
yeah so strange but like their
interactions with humans in real life
like boy if people treated them the way
they think about them in the movies it
would be a wonderful time to be a cop
it's weird though because I remember
that time here in New York like so
strict like I have a different
relationship now when I see cops but but
as a as like a bum kid at 19 like I
remember walking down the street and a
cop would cruise alongside roll down the
window and they'd start taunting me
saying [ __ ] like you know cannolis and
but they're just like waiting for you to
say something back right and it was like
was weird you know I was just walking
down the street I wasn't you know even J
walking down the street now whatever cop
comes up to me like oh no what's
happening like dude I saw you in Slayer
it was [ __ ] awesome I as weird
yeah it's gotta be super strange yeah I
mean they're more accountable now than
ever before I think that's one of the
great things about body cameras and cell
phones cops are you know you just can't
rock it that way before but I don't
think they get enough counseling and I
don't think they get enough money and I
don't think that's I don't think it's a
stringent enough screening process I
think there's a lot of people that are
there you know there are powerless [ __ ]
when they're young and they want all
just wish everybody's gonna [ __ ] if I
could be a cop and they become a cop for
all the wrong reasons and then there are
the ones that give the good cops a bad
name and if you think about the amount
of interactions that people have with
police and this is what perspective is
so important there are [ __ ] 320
million people in this country and cops
have millions and millions and millions
and millions and millions and millions
and millions of interactions with people
yeah all the time but how many of those
interactions are positive the vast
majority of them are not police
brutality the vast majority of men are
not shooting someone implanting a weapon
on them or planting drugs on them of
course vast majority of them are cops
doing a really hard job and doing their
best but nobody gives a [ __ ] about that
you only care when the cops go bad you
know yeah you know it's just perspective
which you know nobody has no that's too
nuanced to have a conversation with the
world no no it's a perspective on
anything well this a man I appreciate
you coming in here and you film is out
tonight tonight tonight it's three from
hell
three from Hell tonight and everywhere
well somebody will tell me they couldn't
find it but it's trying to be everywhere
so and then when will it be available
like if someone wants to get it off
Apple TV um I don't know exactly I mean
it's a three-night fathom event and then
it'll be in theaters here and there and
then it'll be out probably October or
will be most accessible for people okay
I should have brought that information
but don't worry thanks man they'd be
professional in here bro thanks for
having my man thank you Rob Zombie
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
[Applause]